there was the big world economic the wef
the world economic forum event last week
here is video of alibaba group president
j michael evans and uh he's gonna hunt
you people down
we're
developing through technology an ability
for consumers to measure their own
carbon footprint
what does that mean that's
where are they traveling how are they
traveling what are they eating what are
they consuming on the platform so
individual carbon footprint tracker
stay tuned we don't have it operational
yet but this is something that we're
working on
hey you want an individual carbon
footprint tracker so i can see what
you're eating and how your health is how
was that that was that same drug dealer
guy because it's the same thing you get
my point these people want to track you
and confuse you about your gender and
make you think you're racist and get you
hooked on heroin and lock you in the
metaverse with something attached to
your genitals and you ain't ever gonna
leave but there's more they also want to
control what you're gonna say
here's video of australian e-safety
commissioner julie in inman grant
talking about what they're going to have
to do related to free speech because you
people keep saying what you're thinking
we are finding ourselves in a place um
where we're we have increasing
polarization everywhere
and everything feels binary when it
doesn't need to be so i think we're
going to have to think about a
recalibration of a whole range of human
rights that are playing out online you
know from freedom of speech to the
freedom to
you know to be free from online violence
or the right of data protection to the
right to child dignity guys these are
the elites and you can't be making fun
of them they're better than you and
while they're eating steak you will eat
bugs don't you understand while they fly
private you will be masked on a plane
they're better and stop saying all that
mean stuff about them ah
this is pretty beautiful uh this is uh a
journalist an australian journalist uh
avi and yemeni
who went up to new york times deputy
manager editor rebecca blumenstein at
the world economic forum she didn't want
anything to do with it but he had a
microphone and he's a guy
rebecca how are you doing from new york
times can i ask you a quick question avi
from rebel news how is the public meant
to believe that the new york times is
here to actually ask the tough questions
when you're here as an invited guest
[Applause]
how are people meant to rely on the
mainstream media
if you wouldn't mind we're just having a
just if you could give us you know thank
you
you don't want to explain to people why
we should trust the mainstream media
no of course no comment there we go so
that's the point here is in davos you
have the mainstream media that are not
here to report the truth they are here
as part of the event invited guests with
their white name tags
avi yemeni over at rebel news great work
brother i mean that's what it's all
about they invite the media to report on
what they're doing and then you wonder
why they get glowing coverage you wonder
why it always turns out that the people
at the world economic forum their
brother or their cousin or their wife or
whatever ends up working at the new york
times or at washington post or at forbes
or business insider it's all a big
circle jerk that's what it is people so
good work avi i like how what you just
you can't just ask that question we're
trying to have cappuccino we're just
trying to have a nice afternoon
cappuccino
the point of all of this is i feel this
was very therapeutic for me like i got a
lot of the crap that was going on this
week these were things that were just
sitting on us we couldn't fit them into
a show but we were just waiting and
trust me it's just a small amount of the
stuff
that that just happens on each and every
week it's just man just wake up to it
and then once you see it you just see it
you sit with it
you go okay they're [ __ ] artists how
can i live my best life
that's what you got to do